well welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
all right here we go first I'm going
over the new bridge
[Music]
oh-oh-oh-oh
you have it up that was so funny
I can't believe it I Spit my water out I
don't want to turn the wrong earphones
you know living at me dude there's this
all up I can't hear myself you can't
hear yourself no am i off my mic on
yeah it's on no gene hello hello hello
hello oh there it is twist on the wrong
line you wanna know something yesterday
what I had top dog and charl in here
we'll get to that obviously a little bit
later yeah 30 minutes into talking to
them
I play something for them to watch and
my guy goes I can't hear it and I go you
can't hear it thing is no I go what can
you hear me right now and he goes no oh
my god he never played then now they're
all oh that would headphones on on drugs
not even like didn't it occur to you
that there's no sound coming through
yeah it's so funny because they're so
accustomed to whatever is happening like
they just you know it's kind of like how
busy is yeah I give you put like a towel
on her head she just let it stay there I
want to I give credit for that song that
oh my god River by Matt Mercer that was
so funny the way he spit out I took a
sip of water and then I had to spit it
back into the Fiji bottle it was so
funny it was great the composition of
the dad boner is outstanding his
enthusiasm is just ridiculous yeah look
at the river he's so excited about
driving on a fucking bridge somebody
sent in an anti dad boner supposed to
play that little oh goodness
there's a lot to talk about I mean we
had my parents here for five days it was
a world wind situation a world wind
weekend on a whirlwind the world wind it
was a blessing in the skies Wow it was
it was autistic
it was voluptuous
yeah listen over listeners welcome to
all our new listeners welcome to your
mom's house okay and a lot to go over
today oh my god last few weeks have been
big weeks on the show because we had
Martin Risa the water sommelier Vasa
somebody ate that episode got a lot of
traction a lot of people were really
interested in ah what he had to say I
haven't touched our tap water since I
mean Arvin or whatever fine water
differently yeah and said since that day
yeah I've been buying Fiji water for us
I know but also even when in restaurants
I'll say what type of water and the guy
even yesterday he goes we have triple
purified blah blah blah or we have this
spring learner go bring the spring water
yeah I've been ordering it was a
life-changing experience and then mr.
Joe Rogan came last week that was a fun
time that was that was really fun yeah
we got him to drink the Hungarian water
yeah he liked it pretty pretty good
stuff he'll it's super fun um okay well
why don't we why don't we start the show
and we'll go from there and okay Jane
let's do our opening clip and giggles
yes Wow Monday look at the river
taupey Tanner just celebrated her second
wedding in her joy two years ago her
poor dad walked her down the aisle in
public and gave his daughter away to
herself
in what's called Salah gammy Sophie
Tanner married herself yes whole is
Randy don't bring anyone love into this
no mama the phone is dead welcome
welcome to your mom's house
with Sakura
[Music]
there you go
so uh a whole new world just opened up
soon marrying yourself I me wet why are
more women choosing to marry themselves
that bad personalities yeah I'm thinking
um I'm thinking that I could think of a
few reasons sad yeah
lonely you need to look in the mirror
and change things all inside and out
what do you mean why are they choosing
to marry if someone's not just to marry
you then you know here's the thing I
just got problems you yeah I think I
think you just say single right if
you're like hey I'm not into marriage
which is totally valid they want to
celebrate being a single oh like I'm you
know what that's like that's like that's
like the girl who I'm happy been saying
I'm proud man no you're not if you're
happy you just you just are you don't
have to tell people right yeah no yeah
yeah they want it to be they're saying
like these societal norms are unfair and
or just you know not recognizing that
that's something to celebrate in other
words they know elebrate you being with
somebody else but what about celebrating
me not being with somebody else mm-hmm
she said everyone celebrates getting
together with someone and becoming
married but there's no milestone in
society that celebrates escaping
something awful or returning to your own
happiness Oh heaven ouch escaping
something awful that is that what she
thinks marriage is like I wonder what
maybe she escaped a bad relationship oh
right that and that's a different story
that should be different party only yes
yeah it's not I don't want a wedding
talaga me Erica Anderson who of course
lives in Brooklyn also married her
support I mean it's hard not to adopt
whatever society's messages are and I
certainly think that one of the messages
is you are not enough if you are not
with someone else or you could just
ignore societal messages and not have to
do something um she seemed cute enough
right yeah I'm sure she's fine
yeah I just must be what you talk to her
you're like oh guy she's a nightmare
don't you fuckin marry yourself
we'll are they a lot yeah yeah well I
don't know man yeah I don't know about
yeah I'm acting like this is a good
thing hello no I think again I don't
care I don't give a shit
the thing is I think they want the
celebration of a wedding and like they
want to wear the dress and stuff I
totally get that
in which case isn't that kind of like a
quinceanera or like a coming-out party
yeah can't we call it something else
like marrying yourself it's kind of sad
right so would you rather marry yourself
or ask someone you ever date your mom oh
my god I'd marry myself I'd stay alone
in general like my mom it's just like
the gays what would you do of course I
would marry myself yeah over dating my
mom of course that's so crazy I don't
know I mean look I feel like I've made
fun of so many of these people and then
you get to know why and then you're
always like oh okay well she was also
abused or whatever yeah but just don't
do this
that's what I would say too I think it's
just robably a nice lady if you talk to
you be like I understand but also could
you just not do they not be annoying and
also to do you have to divorce yourself
like this you have to make this leap
right well what are these this isn't
legal to begin with right silly not
recognize you can't walk in and go are
you single or married I'm married not
married you I married to me
yeah it's stupid you know what summer
say to you stop fucking around
stop being mentally ill yeah nothing
crazy being crazy it's like in France
they let you marry dead people mm-hmm
which is like not it's also no point
yeah yeah calendar says marry my dog or
lonely in a relationship that's not
functioning measures being on your own
and a lot of people don't realize waste
your life waiting for the one when you
are the one yourself boy
yeah I mean these are just cutting out
these people they need to find
therapists yeah you need to find your
therapist you know you're not fooling
anyone
first of all you know I'm too strong I'm
strong woman that's why that's why men
can't handle me I'm strong woman yeah
you're just you're annoying nobody likes
you there's always that thing I do feel
like it comes from women almost
exclusively you know not to be
accurately the can't handle me yeah
mentality hi guys I never
here guys say she couldn't handle me bro
like guys never say that to women a lot
of women who are crazy
just say stuff like he just can't handle
my success or like then I my personality
or I'm too successful I'm too big
because like that's not why too much
this like he's joke you know I think he
needs a girl I'm a woman right looks
like that's all code for you need if you
need help yeah I remember I went out
with this girl a couple times in college
yeah and then I blew her off and then Oh
months later you know I ran into her and
she had this really snappy like she was
she acted like everything was cool
and she was like have you found a girl
because I know you like girls like the
young girls and not women ice-t-- wanted
to be like look you're built like a
fucking linebacker like that's that's
why we didn't go out again is that why
ya just wasn't attracted it was a
physical yeah so you thought maybe it
could work and then you got a look at
her and you're like now I just know I
went out we had dinner and we had drinks
right and you go like this is a
interesting person everything but I'm
not track what you supposed to do
there's nothing you can't force you
can't force him your trophy and that's
the part that sucks about dating is that
you can't just tell somebody roots like
hey dude you know what I'm just not
feeling you know chemistry
there's no key yeah yeah I'm like I
could have conversations with her
because she was really intelligent it
was fun to talk to her right I enjoyed
it but like I'm not into you in that way
what was their tit situation it was like
a small medium situation so they weren't
hungry they weren't super hungry no full
they were enough yeah but like I just
you need them fat and sloppy yes I mean
two big slaps
big milk drops big G cups uh thing I
want to put on a bucket under those tits
I'm strip all night spewpa I've had that
too like um when I was dating people
back before Friendster was around Jenny
when I started dating and I always found
it hard to tell somebody that like you
know what bro is just not like I can't
say that I don't feel it's a horrible
conversation to have I can't have that
well because they'll always interpret it
as like I'm not enough which of course
and it's a normal reaction to be like am
I not enough and they're not cool enough
for this person of mine attractive am i
- this - that you're like no dude they
could be a fucking loser and you did you
a huge favor by Rory bro
yeah it's but marrying yourself isn't
that like a public declaration of
sadness like well here's another person
no this is another level this is another
level and also this lady's sort of a
dead ringer for you - how fuck I'm
serious I hate you I'm serious okay here
we go
I love her out with though no boy
oh boy you hear she said she's marrying
a train yeah what a train my PO a train
depot the train station essentially but
I noticed that her gear is a lot like
that you would wear creamier if you had
what I want love her face I love her
fame is like a onesie Helle I do
she had similar cans right yeah do you
think she's writing a good bro Jack Jack
Jack Jack no no she needs to come with
me to Nordstrom and get a get fitted but
I like her style I like where she's
going in life yeah I almost have more
respect for her marrying the train
station yeah just because it's something
outside of yourself a little a little
air in yourself yeah it's very
narcissistic and solipsistic to be like
I love me me me me then your urine if
you're if you're all about you your
whole life you're going to be miserable
at least she's into the train station
man for our listeners can you describe
her about the size saying you with dark
hair
can you can you yeah yeah
totally me is she's me she's my twin
yeah brunette she's okay she's a little
bit of what you would call dumpy yeah
that's a dumpy look like it's like a
mechanic's outfit with pink she's not
wearing a bra at all so they're really
low and hanging yeah and then she's got
like an awesome fanny pack is black yeah
just kind of she looks like droopy dog
yeah a little bit yeah but whatever did
she happy wheels kids man they dream
and I know her oh it's lesbians in my
life partner mm-hmm my wife Daedra had a
say Daedra save her name she has to
share her wife with all these people to
not upset her doesn't seem like she's
that upset
look this thing has a water bottle in it
I know this isn't they should be like up
around this area right she's out wrong
yeah I could just hire and that's all
that is is a lack of a bra I would the
right size yeah she has something on I
see it here could be no I think it might
be the wire all right they'll love it
they're sitting right now hang it Wow
dude I don't know I mean that'd be
better for her back that we're good was
better for everybody it's actually
better for all of society if she does
because we don't want to look at it it's
like that woman we saw at the restaurant
yeah there's a lady that walked into the
restaurant we were dining at who had
hangers just like that it was they were
lower though they were down here near
the waist she has bad all buttons the
whole broad switch it's all bad and but
that lady was wearing like a lycra top
and the restaurant screws so the fabric
is very unforgiving it shows your flaws
and so the tits had picked up momentum
like you know when they hit each other
they go in circles and they hit each
other and then she sat down and then we
all took turns getting up to go to the
bathroom right but they were under the
table yeah they were sitting under the
table imagine that you're at a table and
some ladies tits are sitting underneath
that evil that's where they were okay I
tell you as somebody who when I take my
bra off this is what might it look like
now more or less no but I wear bras do
because I don't want to present myself
like this like a crazy person
together no boy
the enema cover Oh I realized I was in
love look at her when I have trouble
staying away from her when I had to go
home I made it when I had to go home I
really could see you wearing that no I
kept - yeah no I feel like you've worn
versions of that probably I actually
pointed out output to your mother
yesterday identical to that uh Norseman
I did you think she's mentally ill yeah
severely but at least again this is an
externalization of of one's stuff you
know what I mean like at least give your
love to something or someone a building
an external oh boy kissing energy
touching the walls yeah I like how she's
miked and we you pick up yeah the audio
only from the camera really good job
guys
[Music]
together Oh also her in the building
watch buildings yeah yeah she's not
doing so we're hobby if you don't
understand why I'm Oh laughs I don't
understand why there
they have to love each other but I
respect them and I hope good luck
hmm there should be a mutual respect for
I guess so I guess I the ultimate
question marry yourself marry a building
near your mom I fuck I'd have to choose
that fuck god of time I choose a
building really yeah because I think
it'd be like we are least you're
technically married to something if it's
a really beautiful buildings yeah and
then and the environment is fun to go to
yeah I would say married to a building
yeah me too
like the Empire State Building supercool
yeah that's a good building would they
let you marry it who cares so many
tutors yeah no true Dom oh yeah that'd
be cool I remember asking where that
notre dam was went to a local policeman
yeah I got off a subway and I was like I
learned that I think it was like ooh a
then not so dumb after I went well well
anything about that did she did that pop
off I said you just attempted it and
okay I just nodded the whole time and at
the end he was like huh there you go
thank you sir don't ask Mel see Merisi
buckets
Marisa buckets man uh what would you do
you barren building or would you marry
yourself not very building for a while
like I said if it was a really nice
building and I like the area yeah I can
go to the same place wait a while what
if we just married this house I'll be
way easier yeah yeah I do and you not to
go anywhere the only where you hang out
your spouse all the time what about this
level and you marry your mom 21 year old
sock LaRue no of Asarco works in the
supermarket and things in a J pop band
his girlfriend's name is monogamous 16
they're a Love Plus couple here fuck you
slips into the role of a schoolboy and
meets the virtual Manasa while playing
the game so it's a simulation dating
mm-hmm like that movie right oh I've
seen that yeah that's a good movie does
he give me that
can forget everything we got Lena I
attended I went over to school I decided
to check out the tennis team I first saw
Monica she was tending the grounds and
we had a chat you all Authority how our
relationship started since then we
become closer and closer well what's
your fucking pronoun it doesn't seem to
be the one I thought it was yeah what
kind on is is they they uh you know
teeth
what's your pronoun they got teeth
pronoun look at those 2 phases p.m.
really really kind of tone that line of
pronouns soccer aruna spends about 3
hours a day with his virtual girlfriend
she's always with him runs on Nintendo
DS a mobile emulator sorry once had a
real girlfriend too but not for long now
devoted to Menaka alone devoted I love
when they say shit like that like
someone's devoted to their car that they
are having sex with or a video game she
is though I know that's a but the
problem with it was healthy now it's not
because it's just gonna further his
isolation because I'm on it I'm sure he
yeah loads he makes her do stuff you
think so
Colin time just just is on the screen
yeah nothing's covered you think so
coated you guys do it somewhere yeah
yeah it's disgusting that's the real
question where are you getting that nut
I mean I can get it on a building all
right cover your keys you could get a
real problem it could seep into those
little all right because you know one
would wonder about people's iPhones is
now where everyone's watching their porn
anyway oh yeah the people is on there I
mean some people I'm sure you just on
your hand and then you touch your iPhone
others jizz on your iPhone oh come on
yeah on your hand you don't know where
does it go on your stomach or you know
your shirts or something how am I sure
yeah I'll lay out your clothes jizz on
that when you're gone well I don't care
my mind care glass all
over glasses yes those good ma'am is a
sad but man yeah
it bums me out but then I know how
lonely some people are and this is like
their only outlet no no then you're like
oh fuck just meet a person yeah
can you swipe right on someone on tinder
or something well I can now you should I
have come all over my face all the other
earlier games separated reality and
virtuality but when you play love Plus
real life and the game meld with one
another there hasn't been anything like
that in the gaming world before yeah I
don't know man
I mean it seems like it really is for
the loneliest it is it's like those sex
robots like they're constantly trying to
make a woman that's a robot so you can
fuck it and not have to talk problems
that just it helps you continue to be
lonely that's the problem
yeah you have to get out of your comfort
zone to meet people yeah and that's
that's tough hey hey what's going on
she's rolling the cup yeah I mean it's
like you just get your super you're
super lonely you're dating your fucking
Nintendo yeah and then you're you're
planning a you know fucking trenchcoat
hit on somebody that's a problem yeah is
that it further isolates look human
beings are meant to be social creatures
you can't stay in isolation and we can't
foster it yeah don't don't marry
yourself
don't marry your fucking Nintendo and
don't marry buildings go go find some
other freaks it's like you and that's it
to find happiness right on is real an
old relationship on my develop at least
in particular Stefan's it's like okay
now Trust is the most important thing in
a relationship many brave desire is a
partner I can trust
she's never cheat on me that's why I
prefer her to a real girlfriend yeah
well I learn how people get hurt one
time by want that one issue and now it's
forever that thing like everyone's going
to cheat on me and again I can't ever
trust again like dude no there's other
girls in our computer it's rusted it's
just my building just my building
but even though people are logging in
and out of a road
read a know the other pigs on her I feel
like she would never break my heart I'm
not nasty
um how's your butthole today it's pretty
good yeah I had a really rough week you
back on back on abnormal dr. Brown it
was really bad
you said you're going to name your next
album no more diarrhea yeah no more
diarrhea like mary j blige is no more
drama but I had a real bad diarrhea
I had an upper respiratory infection and
I got an antibiotic I had never had this
happen where I had the worst side
effects of this antibiotic which were
which was intense diarrhea pretty
Italian took me down for a couple days
so sterile yeah all right couple emails
we should get into look-see hi Hitler's
right after finishing up episode 396 I
knew I had to email you of my
observations that may give some more
insight on the big mystery who is the
real water champ even though it really
is in a mystery the Tom is the champ
it's being alright just on a mere listen
from your conversation his margin the
Tom's knowledge about the contents what
was in each type of water was vastly
superior to mommy Tina's okay at times
as though as if Tom actually knew what
was in the water before Martin even said
anything about the water even where it
was from this may stem from Tom
superiority with accents when mommy Tina
York accept her water she was clearly
dumbfounded on what she was even tasting
and she would have thoughts about what
she tasted it reminded me only of Helen
Keller's excited cries of wata when she
discovered how to speak I hope I was of
some help to add on the amount of
evidence for pro Tom the water champ
thanks and see you in Brest Falls beach
Michael hmm
well Michael I hope to see you in
westballz Beach so I can hit you in your
dumb face because that's stupid how to
spot a psychopath they're dumb oh I like
this one hi mommy I'm living I'm an
American living in Singapore I'm sure I
spotted a complete psychopath on the
public bus yesterday it was high in
tight cisgendered businessman in his
suit but something is terribly wrong
I noticed he was wearing his watch over
the sleeve of his shirt how
what an obviously psychotic fashion
choice absolutely reason I can think of
to wear your watch over your sleeve is
to detonate some type of remote bomb
I would rather wear orthopedic shoes as
earmuffs weigh in on this thanks Jean
Jake Jake you're completely not a
percent right a couple times
am I crazy look yeah it is really
bizarre I think I did it in third grade
and then I realized how lame it looked
yeah and you're like I can't wear my
swatch over my sleeve I also by the way
I've seen it more so I know some people
more people do it
I think it's bananas when people wear
their watch on the inside of the wrist
that's terrible yes they do I hate bad
fun why would you do that who's here
than shit it doesn't it doesn't look
like a bracelet bro like everyone knows
it's a watch just for your watch is I
like a watch
yeah weirdo you fucking asshole everyone
hates you and now I resent people that
wear their watch on the right oh you're
right have two wrong - so if he lab did
always on the left but why is it on the
left oh no because I think is the whole
thing was that more people are I think
they said that right-handed people put
on their left and more people are
right-handed yeah that's it but then why
wouldn't you put it on your dominant
hand so that you're always looking at
that hand because then the dominant hand
is free I had to do what you need to do
a hindrance of the watch got it but that
that is a psychopathic over look that's
crazy I can tell you what I feel is
another psychopathic look and I know I'm
going to get some pushback on it it's
very very racy but the sandals like the
ones I showed you today I'm the Vienna
quest and all that are like strappy
dress with dad sandals with socks of
course that's not cool I would get
pushback because I know those people are
going to email me like I wear it that
way because I know hi oh my god each
slit arrabal they don't get excusable it
is no excuse to wear those periods with
a little bit outside oh my god Avery
rendus there's other options out there
you know we're talking about those strap
on going skating show them because I I
feel like there's Birkenstocks we're not
talking about Birkenstocks
Birkenstocks are ugly too by the way
these are the fully functional dad
sandals or mom's animals our King bill
either way yeah it's usually the mom
sandal actually it's the woman who's
totally given up yeah
oh my god I gave up on everything yeah
the terrible oh all Beach basic Oh
terrible there's no excuse there's
really no wait go back to the strap I'll
do better
Oh terrible
athletes oh my god those are like look I
wear orthopedic shoes you like youngest
nails nancy ash on the back here and she
totally those are like Shaq's feet go in
there but look let me show you so I'm
wearing orthopedics right now yeah but
they're like look these are our two
Pedic people watching I'm listening into
the camera you can see they're like
ballet flats they're nice yeah
you wouldn't even know that's like I
give up
but everything is shut down my Jennifer
glows yeah those are terrible then you
shouldn't show your vagina shut yeah
unless you hear see a lot more dudes in
there than I see well my god I see women
with dude haircuts wearing those yeah of
course that's when you've given up the
hair yeah they stopped coloring it yep
and then they put those on they're like
yeah I gotta get kind of get when I
gotta get I'm out there taking care of
life yes it's not what happens it's
usually couples who wear those together
and they're like 60s they start to shut
it down sexually you'll see some in
Denver by the way those are total Denver
shoes I know I didn't want to say that
but yes they are Denver Jews of course
because they hide yeah yeah Patagonia
just like being outside these are just
comfortable and you know they get the
job done where they don't know they're
terrible dude there's nothing in this
world that can make me wear those jeans
no I promise you as your wife I will
never wear those I will never wear these
oh those are sandals with a heel yeah
those are terrible I'll tear all these
are carefully there's no I also actually
buy icy but whenever I see burdock so I
always know the lefty I just feel like
they stink well I feel like they do too
because the are they usually are black
like if you look at the under the foot
of the person they're always black
they're worn down you sweat on them and
the letter get this some type of write
the texture of the accurately gross they
look funky yeah they would let you smell
by guess they're comfortable right
because a lot of people love them people
love their burger and I guarantee we can
get a lot of pushback on the Burke's
when I lived in San Francisco a lot of
people would endure terrible speaking of
feet hairball this came in my girlfriend
and I were having this discussion today
she said the only time I ever wash my
feet is when you're in the shower with
me and you make me the rest of time they
get washed in the soapy water done and
down my body yeah I on the other hand
the firm believer in washing of the feet
can the mommies discuss this James well
James I'm with your girlfriend great
topic I don't wash my feet I don't
either I feel like you just pee are you
so a minute well he is sterile
sterilizes come on you're gonna be so
fucking nasty on swed truth and call it
reality so but I'll tell you what I had
an ex-boyfriend who was very type a very
meticulous
you know folded his shirts with a
folding board yes we didn't last
obviously I know you didn't wanna I'm a
total animal yes but he would insist on
washing his feet in the shower really
and I remember being blown away and I
had to pretend like I did that too
regularly like oh yeah your wisdom yeah
like I totally shower yes I totally wash
my feet
I don't not why I mean I get pedicures
and then they scrub them like they get
in there yeah no I never do Oh before I
mean unless there's something like
there's like I step on tar or something
you know but that's it yeah I mean I'm
in the pool I feel like that washes it
my feet are clean I don't have I don't
have feet are clean I never never
smelled your feet yeah I've never like
been you know Luke Dow some people do
have just naturally funkier feet so
maybe they need to ya know my feet are
sweaty but like they get washed in the
shower yeah we bring up Shaq's foot o
load too well I keep thinking about it
it was a during playoff coverage nasty
few days ago I think on TNT they were
doing whatever they were doing a remote
shot and were there at the game
and Shaq took his shoe off back off and
showed his size 22 foot kind of dog do
you think is on that guy I don't know
it's always been a big point of
discussion about whether it's yeah it
measures up to his enormity because
people I think the rumor is that it
doesn't in other words it really not
that it's like teeny-tiny it's just that
it's not in proportion to his we got a
dick collective this one no does anyone
had sex with Shaquille O'Neal can you
let us know yeah
now the big question is which we've
debated hotly on this show is whether or
not those things are correlated whether
or not hand-sized is correlated to
penile size or an indicator of penile
size yeah foot size let's see here oh oh
boy shag the big tell is look at this
it's like morphed poof poor guy
Oh Nancy ah the big toe is what troubles
me it just it smashed to the right I
remember the he not wearing shoes that
fit when he plays no no it's like a lot
of athletes particularly in basketball
because you are stopping Oh
wrapping money and they play these you
know their seasons are 82 game seasons
right and then you practice every day a
lot of them have really fucked up feet
you tried to maintain they would design
shoes to help that I don't think it's
that the shoe is a problem it's just the
level of activity it's so much more than
you know you're you're constantly
pivoting jumping rang someone stompin
just yet and then and then you play a
game the next day and the next day and
the next day and the next day I remember
Jordans feet were super fucked up saw a
photo once he hang out yeah okay I mean
if you want to see it yeah I kind of do
they're really fucked up dude it's so
important to wear good shoes especially
the older yet now that I'm into
orthopaedics I really I can't I can't
even wear flats like regular ballet
flats they really hurt yeah I can't do
it dude since I had a kid I just fucked
up my whole alignment everything backs
off
lots of hipster all messed up I remember
it was in a book it was like I had a
book I had a book of it I've none of his
feet but of him and they he was on the
trainer's table and I remember the
comment from his wife was like I can't
believe you let him take a picture of
that yeah because she didn't she was
kind of like trying to protect him you
know
Wow but I don't see it oh well yeah it's
really common for these athletes have
super funds at it that Jordan
so no Chicago Bull your uncle's are well
they're all taped up because that so
there's something running yeah well his
nails are all jacked up yeah they're all
mucked up we're all fucked up but it's
just from from being crazy athletes it
sure is I know what that's like
yes you sure do I had the best thing
ever happened to me on the flight home
from New York from Jude or Kitty's yeah
I was wearing the Jean sweatshirt it's
like my favorite thing now I wear all
the time and the stewardess was I'm
sorry flat head I got such a cisgendered
comment yeah um she comes up to me and
she goes oh is it gene or Jean I'm from
Montreal and I was like it's Jean you
shouldn't says Jean Jean I couldn't lie
to her I should have said Jean I
couldn't you lie to work I just didn't
think of it on the spot I'm so like I'm
so earnest in real life I can't dude I
can't be I can't lie this nice people
Jean our Jean Jean Jean I really like
that I wish I hadn't recorded there
calling this guy the anti dad boner okay
so you know the dad boners obviously
really lose their mind and they
celebrate this yeah they just are you
know you can't you can't bring a dad
boner down right they just they get
excited about anything really yeah oh is
this muted sorry oh my god it sounds
like an elk oh now they get excited oh
that's a dad boner if you're new not as
a dad but this guy is upset about things
it's different grumpy dad I've been
searching father halls
I live long honest ah look at this shit
you got a ride in the middle of the
fucking Road hi Edie fuckin zone it's
fucking terrible
oh my suck oh my god
look how bad that road that is terrible
we're gonna shit oh my god what you hear
what do I do it
guys stop God get over on your car I
talk and move it what the fuck door oh
my god look ahead
fuck a fucking head okay it's like my
life is that I feel like I put quite a
start it's just fucker this is what kind
of dad I'd rub with yeah well it's good
job you somewhere I like this you guys I
fire it up kick is dirt like a dog
probably well that's terrible I don't
select your tires I saw man yo oh my god
this is ridiculous he's right it is it's
not going damn I pay taxes and that road
is just completely battered man oh it's
no good
potholes are my fucking log where's
fucking wall in my life I'm gonna where
he is I don't know I'm brick get Road
America piece of shit motherfucker yeah
we're fucking Road America he's just
yelling at the road though yeah no one
even comes on his fucking Road mmm-hmm
hey know better
I've driven all right it is unnerving to
drive on this high a fucking war zone
fuckers that's how I blew out our tire
gene really on the ark arm that's how it
happened I was on a pothole on Sunset up
towards the 405 yeah and I took one too
fast and the guy says look I could tell
was a pothole that did this to your car
he told me he showed me how oh I'm gonna
go slow very cautious and it's like a
naive treasure camel
fuck it terrible that shit how you're
gonna be I'm in fucking town right here
let me follow at that what the fuck what
fuck fuck look look at that
I'm believing that isn't believing it
look at this shit I'm just fucking
kidding me that's pretty bad my
taxpaying fuckin dollars doing good
point I just thought are they doing yeah
imagine you're walking by seeing that
guy making it no all right we gotta get
to this yeah if you're a new listener to
the show one of our all-time great
regulars on this show has been my father
ah and sometimes my mother and yesterday
I had them in here for a little sit-down
where I got to just talk to them in
general and also catch up on some some
show topics and even play some games
with them I can't I mean when we are
prepping the games I was so excited I
want to sit in here to listen but then I
thought it probably better if I wait
until we play it back but we also spent
the last week with them we haven't even
thought about that you know and we got
to hear so many wonderful stories from
them about your home soon Donna when I
can't pronounce words she always says
well my favorite moment by far it was
when we were looking for a movie to
watch and your dad's reading off the
actors and what did he say Tom he's like
Chris Pratt and Emma Stone and Vincent
Nonna freon I almost shit so he goes
Vincent done a fully on her then you
repeat it right away
and I and I don't know what I enjoy
everywhere music air is when he talks
and he says something wacky or when you
repeat it perfectly cuz we do a really
good impression of him it's like hearing
him in stereo he also he mispronounces
words that I don't like years right he
would say PDO v my PDO file and I would
go every time you said it I would know
is trying to say but I would go what's
that and he would turn to me like a guy
that fucks kids right I'd say so you
mean pedophiles
yeah yeah and then you just move on I go
why do you keep saying it wrong like
what
or like we're both news junkies right we
both read news watches you know be like
did you hear this
Steve Banyan hits ban him I go you hear
it a hundred times a day
yeah it's the same guy yeah weeks it's
not a guy that they mentioned once no he
sees the word he hears it pronounced and
how he mispronounces it over and over
but I think it's because he doesn't have
an ear for like music or language you
have to have an ear i right that's a
good point you have to be tuned into it
and he's just not tuned in see they were
saying this Jerrod coached her has
gotten like Jerrod Jared Kushner yeah
like why are you why are you saying
Jerrod right he's getting these confused
with Carmichael yeah it's big Carmichael
van yeah
yeah it's so bizarre to me so I think
you'll really enjoy I'm gonna mute wait
our mics just to hear how to start it's
audio only people will always inevitably
go why isn't there video of them they're
old they don't want to be video yeah you
know it's just like when you bust out a
camera moment we like go away they can
picture what how much it won't be on
camera so it's believe me the audio is
more than sufficient Vincent
Donofrio just Ramone I'm going to mute
us okay you can hear this only because I
want you to that is a legendary uh heavy
breather - so here you go
um definitely breathing that's for sure
can you kiss are you talking to
microphone mom no go can you hear me -
[Laughter]
okay there you are
let's see cuz your birthday holy shit
when it's up at that tutorial briss I
mean I see not do those if you're going
to go is it sorry babe yeah okay
you can't I just think even if I don't
don't feel bad from go ahead am i could
have to fart why we do this show now
please don't I can't help it and that
you got to leave if you have to do that
just leave you're not going to tight
space don't do that just get up and
leave without side seriously seriously
no really really really ruin this we
won't be able to do it does it smell
that bad how can you act like you don't
know it smells open so we had a moment
earlier you don't know what happened I
think you forget what you did I think I
let me kid down yeah I had walked into
the and just entered the living room
like I'm not kidding you it smelled like
a sewage canal and I go what the fuck is
that because I just had a little one I
was like and my mom I go because she'll
think that you know because I go just
walk towards the living room
yeah she turned on she was like oh my oh
yeah my god smells like a sick person
yeah it doesn't it doesn't smell normal
well like diarrhea well he farted in the
car when we were on the way to the
country club and I smelled it I didn't
want to talk about it but it was really
rancid oh it's like we're Snape Amsale
this was worse yeah
so I was just telling my dad go if you
fart here this is over well this is a
small studio and no you can't fart it's
not like other people's farts people
understand it's really not oh my god
remember when they farted in front of
our nanny he started loudly because we
were watching movie and there would be
like a scene where like the scene fades
out and my mom went wrong
sorry night turn and walking past the
living room I was like just mouth drop
and I saw her head turn Hey she's like a
nice Guatemalan lady she doesn't do that
no there's no no no that way
my mom was more to say later I know she
heard you fucks y-yes
Tim it smells no no no you know and
actually calculating look at any
infections it actually was like a like
it was actually scary how about that
smells really that had been anybody else
or it was you I would tell somebody
immediately go to a doctor I said I'm
not gonna joking not your thing it's
funny but I probably left my friend of
us always smell like that no no we all
have our own fingerprint in the
intestines okay nothing about that
smelling is remotely normal it smells
like it smells really really different
doesn't smell normal I can use
injections or infection telemedicine
because I've had that normal smell for
years what I would mix a room is open
the ship it would be livid hey come on
there you are
take me outside thank you so much oh
yeah because you had questions from what
I wanted to I wanted to add more ideas
yeah okay yeah I wonder if now you can't
hear it but sometimes you can hear what
yeah going okay so I think I think we
wouldn't we let me lead right into that
okay yeah all right
Christina asked me to ask you how you
like your new bra I love it rules the
experience like oh my god I feel like a
normal human being
do you hear my dad breathing yes it's
alarming not just for the listeners know
your mother I know how to put this
delicately she's big slow
purrs like me yes but she's been wearing
the wrong size bra for her whole life
purse that you knew this already i
eyeball the kazakh
from one big tip monster to another i
look and i go you need to go to
Nordstrom you have a girl measure you
because they're trained and I we got
heard the right fit and it changed
everything she looked amazing
and it did stuff I feel like a half
actually how about you sit back here so
sit back yeah I have to book lift
without paying for the booklet really I
can jump up and down to the move I am
sexy yeah I kinda didn't think inception
because what happened was Christina took
you and you were wearing a bra that that
they'd all be measured you but I was
wearing all my life it's very person
yeah and I plan to be
that's a D G some sort of the layers and
make any sense but the truth is it's
hitting like a close to me look at this
yeah look at this yeah if I got upset
because the books are in place and we're
not passing and say look at a perfect
fit so maybe it's a perfect fit but what
it bothers him is that because they fit
me they are not flying all over and
jumping up and down the way you would
like is that true I think well I think
if you have G yeah oops
key boobs are really gigantic I mean if
you go to if you googled G boobs and
you'll find her you'll find some big
boobs okay
no I think what about thought we got the
explanation that that was a totally
inside I didn't I didn't see that
okay rewriting that society didn't
please be well well I didn't said in
purses I have to Google European
bra sizes versus American okay okay so
when he got up there these are numbers
so 28 let's go to cup size screw the
numbers okay okay we're talking cups
really numbers are per cup you want to
get into the real tits you got to go to
the cup size okay see what this shows
here and a little credit them with
address teachers
is it a picture similar because it can
ring okay cut Ron's boss I was
controller maybe this a bit I make sense
to him you know what key pause for
saying yeah yeah I think he was upset
because he felt gypped right because we
came home and I texted her mother hey
what a top dog think about your new
boobs yeah and she texted me back he's
upset he's disappointed yeah and then
you said I said it's because he wants
them spelling out right so the the bra
that it's ill-fitting is exciting to him
because tests are falling out of it so
he feels gypped like he feels like we we
snuck in yeah
and ruined his his tit pleasure yeah
yeah true
interesting okay I'm at April be so G
here yeah is Triple D USA okay now can
you show me how those big two threads
how did that start
yeah keep it simpler Tommy shit can you
make them hi yeah it's a good attention
paper what if people want to know if you
can show them how those big tits fart I
would taking this serious look okay
let's get to he went it far yeah
oh he sing the song he is in the heroin
yeah um this was a song that we sing all
the time yeah we sing it in the car and
then she came up with her version can
you do use one we wanted vodka with
talking real fire but at five five five
yeah excuses five really good all right
it ended in the time it was the original
song anything you wanna part can you
really press
can you really practice do you one two
five you're running on two five and the
five five five wow I was a lot that was
really I really hope that at least maybe
one of our genius musical listeners can
do something with that create a real
tune out of that I think it's already
working it's already happening you
didn't answer prayer oh no that was the
one you had this morning in the bathroom
you offer both of you for it in front of
our nanny but I think I wasn't going to
talk about that you did butters he
doesn't look at many decibels higher
than I ever was really son I gotta study
this disk up sighs turn what do you
think do this it says right there I do
up key Europe G Triple D Triple D yeah
people eat or eat or actually for UK
yeah it is UK G would be an S but that
makes sense
so you're I am a Triple D yeah so that
makes sense that makes sort of sense but
we were doing everything wrong because I
was using city for I'm 30
yeah and I told me the thirty was a
little tight no it's good stretch it a
little
so today school what is it what is your
disappointment in these broads because
it's just kind of flattened everything
yeah I don't believe each what no
cleavage what I like ladies room how I
told you ten Bush first time can't avoid
it but cleavage cleavage I've always I
was raised on cleavage okay yeah right
why would I see this when I was you know
a good little Catholic boy and we're in
the movie so you didn't have all you had
was cleavage yeah in those days there
was a game you know so leave it you
that's not that's not pushed together
cleavage that's see so that's what it
was yeah the comfort provided by the
good fitting bra eliminates what he
liked fell over yeah well here's your
here's the deal you can also buy a bra
that fits and that creates cleavage but
your mother was insistent upon not
buying a bra that was too sexy
so we got our bras that were in a
awkward zone but she didn't want like
the sassy ones is what I'm trying to say
I tried believe me I wanted to I wanted
to do this for your dad more than
anybody like I wanted your mom to come
back with a little sassa tude she was
the first person to ever say tits don't
fart right she was like go but based on
sorry most people don't push back on
that
yeah mr. Center want me to bid on it
smaller for this episode well a little
bit smaller and kind of little cleavage
you're willing to pay for a good list so
we don't need a bowl if you got great
boobs okay you just have the wrong bra
that's all you ever want spoon you want
they have they make push-up bras they
make bras to put them together this one
just flattened everything out seems like
he's making his case you got to respect
the case what it doesn't have a stupid
case over here as well look at is I can
GAMP up and down and nothing move you've
cut yeah I guess you gotta look at it
from your point of view if you're really
good look at it perfect I know I know
but if you're comfortable but so like
cleavage you need to find a different
woman next Oh how's the trip in for you
so far at the best lawyer inventor not
honestly the best trip ever in every
sense from the minute that we got in the
bling and that is spoiling little better
yeah exactly I am talking or no is it by
turns there's there's a Mike home right
here where I'm muted mic really the
breathing is overwhelming to me I I feel
like you have to go to doctors is what
every phone call is like yeah and we
shall be down there yeah yes I did well
the thing we came here I guess aliases
absolutely to die for
yeah it is gracious perfectly good it
carries a beautiful boy however if I
don't do I will take a DNA test I know
I'm doing my tattoo
if it starting to look so much like his
Milan 3 it really is a perfect kid yeah
beautiful and so intelligent he observes
the same we have to bring up column you
did your Mike
bring up one point yeah that that Alice
gave me a lot of kisses and I think you
got I had like grandparent battles right
who could Ellis would give the most
kisses okay yeah yeah first kiss was it
yesterday or today I get me out I'm
about 25 kisses to your two or three
right now know that that's fact we go
way back side kids they have permanent
you know and I think that I don't know
why I am convinced is because I think
it's confidence I told you I got my
theory on it I think he confuses your
father is doing he looks with fingers I
like and he said I don't know not Tommy
as a beard doesn't suit me I'm
clean-shaven every day of my life
that's true it's true so it's it's
really I think it's the the vibes that I
look like maybe I did I so hot yeah you
know what you just occurred to me that
your dad was wearing the same outfit the
whole week yeah like he didn't change he
came over he was wearing khakis that
were too big for him he would buy
furniture at once right but I'm saying
he wore oversized khakis with a belt and
then the khakis would come up over the
belt because it was too big yeah but he
didn't want he didn't want to buy pants
to fit no he went away the big pants
yeah and then he laid on the couch Marie
was laying or watching that movie and
two buttons came undone and then his who
she was hanging out his stomach was
hanging out yeah so funny he hates being
comfortable he is comfortable you got
that right now he says he's comfortable
I am comfortable he came over it was
like a chill day and you're laid in
khakis and a button-down and that was
his comfort yeah howling kind a belt and
loafers that's a comfort
it makes me so uncomfortable is watching
you shirt and sweat pants yeah I can't
do it I get hung up to take everything
off right away I made two in the same
way yeah I walk around on my boxers
gracious sort of the nanny too by the
way
hmm well forget her I know in there I'm
he's right you go in with you hesitate
when you go in you're almost looking for
engine I am
I go in with full confidence I'm going
to get it yes yeah that's true yes I let
me ask you this recently you called me
from the Orlando Airport do you remember
this oh yeah that was really I know
people would want to hear about this
you called me from the Orlando Airport
from the same restroom stall yeah yeah
yeah about you know it was probably
almost almost 20 years ago when I had I
did the little relaxing in the my pants
in the Orlando Airport and I had to
leave my underwear in the stall well
what I did was the other day a little
time I went back and revisited well the
location took a picture of the stall
okay really I did I had a bomb this is
command
you know they made some modifications
the they all make all the places have
bigger handicap stalls now it's the law
yeah
you know but that spot is still there
and went in and you know just kind of
relive the moment you know some people
message me that they're at the Orlando
Airport
you know what stall it happening so they
can go visit it nice Louis cussing is
the terminal side something it's on be
on if you walk out of be back maybe they
want to know what it is so they don't
come up out of baggage claim be and go
to the right before you there it is he
threw his underwear there had to leave
the underwear and even had shit on his
pants but guess what it gets happened to
him again in his office what will you
tell them I told you about that when I
happened a little fumble in the office
recently yeah what happened
I couldn't get as I was heading in there
I thought it had perfect I mean I
remember but I had you know of some
suits they had that other hook yeah and
I had trouble getting that undone and
before I could make the turn and drop
the drawers I had little fumble how much
not a lot but enough to go in the wrong
places where I had to actually you go
home now
what I did was I just
really underwear where I cleaned up in
there and I just wore my suit pants no
underwear no underwear I mean was it on
your leg how stuff to know it was well a
little bit on the leg but I got that
okay
also cheeks I know this is extremis yeah
we thought this is okay and it was a
stinker - I mean yeah that's in the
indication of what comes out I'm sure it
was a thinker
but I mean this is disgusting you're not
thinking I thought about going all mad
and changing but I figured pretty much
got everything done with that one do it
mmm I think you started talking to the
mic no no I am embarrassed why are you
nervous because this is disgusting yeah
mm-hmm just part of like kind of like
the reality getting advanced on yet
floating that and so what do you do
you're under is it I left it in my
office and I want your answer and I hid
in the bathroom where you throw your
hook Jesus or what the kidney people are
coming into so you want where you have
your hands house I just threw it in
there people put ant out snowdrops
nobody's going to see it I'm good paper
towels paper toss oh if I it's all good
though after I did that though yeah yeah
what does any live on here
his office a good sound yeah far you
know that um there's this couple a
mother and son that got married
what yeah can you imagine marrying your
boy your children no that's a joke no no
you cannot marry him your song I know
they just got arrested
waiting wet but forget I'm your mom and
you're my son and I fall in love with
him he says are you really I said yes I
am you think you know what I was scared
let you know - I am - the boat
consenting adult if if it comes down to
it you know it's just like the gays
they're you know
as long as they're already know
everything is fine what yeah
all they want to do is Ellen for
eighteen months so I guess you know I
have never heard a story like this in my
life
no asking will you ever get your mom
into what you date your son I said I'll
shoot yes I would
good nineteen years you're the best
thing that ever happened to me and I
really want to be with you I've done bro
so he said no girl do that is it it's
unconceivable yeah that's pretty good
yeah what is sick minds yeah we used to
be a scared of the teacher with the
student and now now with the mother with
his own mother and son the first
approach was actually we were hanging
out and you know just talking you know I
was just laughing and I looked at her
and she looked at me and I just I kissed
her there's a real kiss the union work
is my lip of course of course you know
it's his mother
yeah I was a real kiss Oh hated I know I
know it has to be a joke I know it's a
real they got arrested
there was an we followed up on the story
they got arrested I cannot believe this
is Tory would you marry your grandson I
the war is going more than crazy now yes
now I'm not kidding you this is it yes
we're getting to experience grace eNOS
yeah you know lead tomorrow you want to
find out your fire really sighing Isis
oh really dad yeah your nicest tell him
that's one organization I would never
even joke being apart the lot of the
listeners want to hear would you rather
with you guys okay they want to hear
what would you rather okay boom button
not related to fire on apartment yeah
breathing yeah a lot did you hear that
yeah
[Music]
drink the top layer tell me did she ask
for a baby the urine she didn't homeless
men though trying to buy my bucket in
music almost giant insects when your
sister take in the face bitter destroyed
the grandmother walks through on you
masturbating never have another orgasm
[Music]
play with rather okay I'm assuming
you've never played this before so what
happens is I present to scenario some
files are coming from recording anyone
is coming from anyways what could what
happens is I present to you two
scenarios okay and you have to pick one
in other words it's two things that are
undesirable so it has to pick one yeah
that's the game it's just like it's a
it's just a logic game and then you
explain why it's in other words I said
would you rather you know eat nothing
but marshmallows or only get to sleep 30
minutes at a time
those are both things you don't want to
do there you go I would take the
marshmallow looks like I could deal with
eating that I have to get like you have
to explain why you chose one or the
other okay so the first one that came in
for you was Charo would you rather eat
nothing but vegetables and you can visit
casinos as much as you want or no
casinos but you can eat anything you
could finish in if you don't even really
such question really I was right it only
vegetables but this is casinos as much
as are really a kind of person that's
how much that means to you and I so
heavily I have no doubts
yeah no doubts pathetic see that's what
she was here absolutely and I would mean
breakfast lunch and dinner nothing but
vegetables you would do it a hundred
percent
I cannot believe it kinda
I think that you're saying that but the
reality would be Taylor is not really
listening that's how much you love to
see my gosh I'm so addicted to his
stupid machines and you're so good at it
yeah I leave it on no no nobody knows
what it is you know about about how good
she is at taking off you know the
cleaners
oh my god he does she cleans the she
cleans a mic yeah okay I came I came I
well he does is they she empties them
out
actually she fills them up with so much
money they have to be taken out and yeah
it's lame that one word I think what was
that but the fact is your mother won't
eat anything that is grown from the
ground and that includes I made
strawberry shortcake for dinner last
night for dessert
she wouldn't even eat a strawberry like
your mother won't even touch a Brussels
sprout even if it's covered in a
delicious sauce and she's super petite
like she's shiny like 105 pounds oh my
gosh but all she eats is cookies sweets
yeah bread with butter it's amazing when
they lie at a physical and like flying
colors
yeah that's a banana but that's why I
thought that was really crazy to ask her
she loves I know I thought to that's
what I'm saying though the reality I
don't think she's facing the reality on
that one it's just that she really does
love casinos right my mom by the way if
you're thinking poker player mm-hmm just
slots man just penny slots changing
pennies okay that is what is the thrill
though just hearing do you guys realize
when you see a win a little bit not
because I never win a little bit so when
where is the idea well number one I
think machines that have been faceless
yeah this is going to be whoever gonna
pay out yes well I mean you get GE a
thousand dollars who came back to the
room a thousand dollars really yeah when
was that
thirty years ago that was uh she goes
along I was Clinton president let me see
yes it was the most exciting team all
you were they and it was it a thousand
in one payout yes yeah that's exciting
and that's exciting because how much
were you betting on that because my
problem with you as somebody that
doesn't do it
as I always think you bet too little no
no I have raised my bed he's the one
who's trying to play me
he said you used to last $100 all night
I was working some casinos I think I
told you and as I'm walking to my to the
showroom I walked by the high dollar
slots yeah so I just put it in the
twenty dollar thing and hit
spin-spin-spin and two out of the three
times I did that I won first time three
hundred dollars next time seven hundred
dollars
get out of here and just end in the will
the last time I lost but so I ran with a
thousand dollars absolutely no sex yeah
60 but again after I did that I just my
another type laser light a casino you
just want to go put some money to see if
you win
yeah yeah yeah for me it's my view in a
garage I have to have my own ideas my my
cigarette yeah my a slot machine that is
going to pay me back
I don't like people around other words
rub cigarette on this trip okay I
understand that shit possible I'm not
there's no casinos in here I usually
like your evening cigarette man oh no
not when she's out of town
but at home don't you have an evening
general actually yes I turn destination
driving you haven't even think about it
that's interesting to me is weird enough
dad would you rather go all on all the
cruises you want but it's only to
Vietnam or you have to wear tight jeans
and loose t-shirts every day you cruise
wherever you want to people that don't
know you have to understand a couple
things yeah he's a Vietnam vet he hates
everything like Asian cuisine and nights
every call that the whole world I think
as a byproduct of getting more there
rightly so and also hates in formalwear
only energies yeah hates them
hates them hates wearing a shirt that's
not collared yeah uh tight jeans and
loose t-shirts and cruise wherever I
want really yeah we're jeans everyday
diet diabetic cruise wherever I want
yeah versus going to Vietnam I get that
get old pretty fast buddy let me tell
you yeah no I'll take the tight jeans
and that
yeah never wear jeans we should today
they're not I know I don't wear jeans I
do have my khakis on right now yeah I
assistance they gave me as jeans for
Christmas not a joke no they thought
anyone ordered them for me really nice
one never through the taxes really the
enforce are nice yeah they're very I'm
saying like there's I think there's nice
designer jeans it actually fit no no
these are like like no I mean if I need
Isis if I go if I go shooting next time
I go clay pigeon shooting I might wear
them really yeah I think even think that
I saw you in a pair of jeans and black
sneakers I thought was really good
actually like he looks great in there
that's what I'm saying they look good on
you
yeah but to me that's an easy one for me
really yeah yeah I think you get so
annoyed by everything I said thank you I
go to cruise anywhere I want to go me
you cannot wait you don't wait whatever
you want to Nicholas you have to wear I
know I get it
I can cruise wherever I want is yeah and
you're begging yeah but you know you
know what up answers and what have to
lay in bed and you have to ask me to
help you pull up the zipper that's true
yeah Charl would you rather be retarded
or you have to drive on the freeway
because I said it did you're thinking
really I didn't notice I can't I can't
hundred thousand people feel sorry for
me convinced it every car in the freeway
first of all this happened one time
we're coming back from going up to
Jacksonville with the Mayo Clinic thing
oh yeah and I think it it just not I am
I am guy I was I did I got frustrated so
she's gonna follow I'm following you
following me okay oh boy I'm getting
behind way she gets by like a truck
this is on i-95 yeah going south not a
truck getting behind a truck mmm it's
going forty five and a seven I feel safe
I should go you know what he did a month
ago he did he pulled out his cards so I
thought oh my god something happened to
your father
so I needed to win there get out and
what happened darling how can you drive
like that Tom he made me shake I am here
in this place before first time it
scared to death I wanted a divorce right
right that one I couldn't because I was
in his place way there we were 45 and a
70 okay I said well then don't get in
front of me and died 45 when I follow
you return of it so what how did you
make this Drive she had to drive it
slower than I have to split a little bit
in how slow did you drive it from
Jacksonville we were under the weight we
got I don't know how many thousand cars
are on the expressway that day we got
passed by everyone yeah you stayed in
the right lane stay in the right I think
he went out on me he went out to 50
excuse me driven 50 yes you are you
being serious
oh yeah I was but it took you seven
hours and to get battery it took us a
long time we can realize how slow that
is yes Your Mother has a crippling fear
of the freeway yeah and you know but she
was like we were driving around our
neighborhoods and and she's like oh I'd
love to live in California except that I
can't take the freeway for those outside
of California substitute highway for a
freeway people think that's a dynamic
what is that like same thing to call a
freeway out here
yeah but your mother was like this is an
ideal place everything's great or digs
perfect but I have to take a freeway
well you can get over that rather than
be retarded right it was me and I saw
every make and model car I don't wreck
truck and I asked him to ask me to
forgive him
yeah well we got them now don't you feel
that's a little ridiculous ah that you
should think up it's such a fear of AI
cannot describe to you really tell me
it's horrendous
you just scared wait I really bitch if I
know
Tiffany's return well okay you're going
to be retired then that's fine dad yeah
would you rather be retarded or you can
only eat Asian food you're not retarded
Q it needs a good one how do you define
Asian food world's like food from China
Cambodia Vietnam Singapore is in Korea
just you know the Asian world that's a
tough one because there's some things in
Asia that I could eat like duck yeah
noodles right it's ready yeah
so if I could have a selection of the
menu yeah I would do the Asian food okay
and if you have to dictate what Asian
food it is if somebody says you have to
eat whatever we're going to give you
yeah I draw the retarted yes oh really
really
you see mentally retarded because I
would want it knowing my ideas I'm done
it's fine I'm not going to eat dog okay
okay I'm not eating dog look ma that's
another Vietnamese thing I can eat that
okay okay there's some things that I
just would never eat so you choose so if
I have a choice yeah of Asian food yeah
like a menu
yeah but nobody want to give you a
choices that wouldn't make any question
I asked okay so let's say there's no
choice it's just whatever Asian food is
given to you now I go retarded okay
now I'm not eating dogs I love dogs do
like okay okay and we are we good I know
it does
they don't really mean in Korea yes one
time I was there they said the street
meat was dog and you don't eat it but
it's not later you think so I'm like can
i really make sure yeah okay that's kid
I mean it's not like all Asian cultures
eat dogs there's a lot of them do okay I
mean it's really prevalent in China only
nothing
choose he wants yes to make a selection
obvious what can you imagine yeah what
kind of punishment is that I got another
good one for your mom to protect would
you rather sleep in a in a cold cold
rooms AC is on like 65 fun like those
but you can you can have all the sweets
you want or you never have any sweets
again but you can sleep in any
temperature you like I can't I know
that's a good one that's from Christina
Christina she's good at these oh shit I
need to be not explaining all the six
rooms or the fun with when it's good so
it's like I kinda never Konya to
assuming so you know sweets you take
temperature I was dying just answer that
you know you just be you just have to
bundle up a lot yeah so why do you
getting a bloody hit danger that's the
temperature is 65 and I can put all the
blankets I want I mean yeah you can put
a blanket on of course okay if I can't
wrap up myself in 50 blankets then I
keep that and get my shirts okay but
every time you walk mmm it's freezing
that's time I am going to be prepared to
just be in boots and five pair of socks
and blanket and a jacket and who lien
I'll get one for you okay so we're doing
yes I rather dad you work in a bar as a
server topless so you wear pants but no
shirt and the guys come up to you and
they're allowed to sexually harass you
like they they pinch your nipples every
time you walk behind me scratch your
chest or you're married to Nancy Pelosi
sitting here I'll take the gay gay bar
thing no problem really
absolutely that's how much you can't
stand her oh I just you know don't get
me going on that death okay
the gate ok range yes sir I mean they're
nice okay guys yeah yeah there are
[Music]
every time they walk by
secondhand lat I could have actually
Susan's excited I think I don't know if
I get a lot of attention I'm sure that
can handle the Nancy Pelosi College
exterior for a year now what if the
ratio is one month of Nancy Pelosi for a
year in the gay bar I could do one
Market Basket below you could do that as
a wife you have to wake up next to her
you have to have breakfast with her you
have to have dinner with her you don't
have lunch with her you have sex with
her look at my other wife I can't
imagine myself having sex she does have
here you are
Justin she does have she's got a nice
set of lungs okay
yeah know that yeah and she said
multiple facelifts and she's had some
work done
she's had some work done I could prop
you know I could try to win but win her
over to my arguments which would be
fruitless of course since I never went
in the argument raised her mother yeah
they don't are you taking months with
you I can probably have a bottle Nancy
Pelosi that's going to cause him he's my
restraint now yeah
do you know Nancy Pelosi is yes do you
think that's not the point
what he will take care she says that she
would be I wouldn't take any woman other
than your mother no matter what the
answer will be yes it's within the game
part of the game yeah while in the game
well why did he go with the gay so what
so nice I think he'd love to be pinching
it did something
okay one more for you okay would you
rather have four penises on your
forehead I got Leo for ten nipples for
fingers I don't like a not pick either
one yeah yeah you have two for peanuts
and I saw so little penises are hanging
from your yeah that's not supposed to be
living four of them no all it is is
there's a little like a weird little
camel woman I know but they're just
hanging from your forehead I Port Vale
or what it means one of your fingers is
a nipple every finger and gift I would
be really excited to have ten nipple
fingertips think about how hard it would
be to do everyday things because you
fingers you have nipples oh you set the
finger yeah you have your nipples on
your hands kind of cute
it's kind of cute I keep the nipples
really yeah what idea I would do dicks
dick heads right on my forehead yeah I
wear a hat like you got on right now and
cover them well I don't know if you're
allowed to cover them didn't stipulate
that I know but it comes up okay yeah
it's a good point I think I would just
keep four little dicks on my forehead
huh yeah I would you dicks it'd be funny
class use my hand that's my point
yeah the hands are really important you
want me to carry you need hands yeah
yeah plus I just like make a living
being like the the dick head girl on
Instagram yeah and I get like a million
followers and when you get really angry
they stand up or something cool really
little tepee of having a sacred foot
penis hanging on my forehead just like
that but it's a good conversation
starter are you out of your mind what
people would be like what's going on
there and I'd be like nothing I have for
peanuts yeah on my forehead well I can
do the same thing with my little thing
and I have the same interesting
conversation definitely with the nipples
in it really yeah okay then that kind of
kids then what would you choose oh the
nipples really move sure how come
because the thing is I see it as the
nipples as
fingers actually make doing so many
tasks almost impossible whereas the
penis on your forehead doesn't keep you
from doing anything it's just
aesthetically awkward right in other
words you still have your full range of
everything you do this right and I
waiting hot that covers any clothes I
got that peanuts hmm it's a good
question now I think they have to be out
but they're just aesthetically weird now
aesthetically most of nowhere
why would you choose the nipples I think
for penises from your forehead it's just
it's so incomprehensible that you
wouldn't feel like going out in society
to begin with I only wouldn't care what
you could do it really
Oh could you think people would be you'd
be that much of an outcast thank you
much I think you would be hole in your
mind
nice and I think you would be you would
make the cover of outcasts magazine okay
yeah
yes I do they are the only good thing
that you will have your own TV show yeah
that's true you think they would just
discriminate against you
oh no they would discriminate against me
they did you know they would and then
you know what happens if some of them
work and some of them don't
okay then you got it real that's called
the ups and downs okay I don't go said
no idea under any table what if some of
them go up and some melee one works yeah
how do you know that because he says
that well you can sing honey in there
true he got so excited about his job
yeah put it down okay what they pee the
dicks could you pee out of your forehead
dangling no I don't think so not in my
mind could you jerk off your forehead
there I didn't picture I picture them
like a gross almost you know yeah so did
I I didn't picture them as functional
pieces but that's a whole other level
now because I might choose finger
nipples if there were dicks at Pete and
Jack ejaculated you know because that's
way more debilitating they don't ever
come in your eyes and Peter forehead
it's true yeah good point and what are
their balls to what do you think I
really wish my parents had thought like
you do right now and asked about that
what about the balls so seriously
there's no balls okay I thought the
gradation so don't get too excited
you don't have that penis deadly one
here you're that common yeah barely one
I have some jokes for you oh good luck
jokes Thanks yeah it was a revisiting
the infamous blonde jokes oh my god I
found a new page of them I think they
just one or two repeats up mostly new
this blew me away I knew how he would
react I was surprised at her reaction
really yes I'm excited to hear these you
do it for blonde throws a grenade at you
yeah I don't know pull the pin and throw
it back what do you call it when a
blonde dies their hair brunette
I don't know artificial intelligence
that's a good one why did the blonde get
fired in the banana plantation I give up
she threw out all the bent ones huh
that's a good one I tell you one sure
okay okay okay he's so excited love
these stupid jokes do you think they're
just simple people
one little I know why your mother is
laughing because I'm sure as a
non-native English speaker like you can
put two and two together and you can
understand those jokes yeah it's a very
Elementary you know yeah for a
non-native speaker for your dad it's
just that's just his jam dude he just he
loves stupid people jokes you know
so this blonde is sitting in a bar in
Chicago I bet you Chicago is immaterial
to the joke what do you think well he's
told me this joke and he told it on our
show already well now this engine
watching the five o'clock news and the
guy sits down next to I remember the
hand
God says looking up the TV and there's a
guy on the ledge of a building getting
ready to Johnny mail and the guy says to
the woman I bet you he jumps and the
woman says you're on I bet you he
doesn't well the guy jumped and the
woman says well I guess I owe you a
drink and he says I really can't take
your money because I saw it on the 4
o'clock news that he jumped she says I
saw it too but I thought he'd changed
his mind that's pretty funny
you told me that one before yeah I got
another one if you want it is it give
you one I've heard before of course it's
about the woman in the airplane going to
London I mean you've already told me
this at least 25 times okay that's fine
Ewan what do you call a smart blonde I
give up
a Golden Retriever I like it I give up
he still doesn't get it you just play
you go longer right what what not I
don't I give up I don't know I'm
searching him yeah you know needs it's
not a guessing game I think he tries on
one of these the jug about the polisi
captain yes okay yeah you probably want
me to come up with some new jokes
eventually it would be nice and work on
that how do you make a blonde laugh on
Saturday
I give up tell her a joke on Wednesday
like I tell you should just go how how
you make yeah how ya play long I give up
that's funny I feel like that one you
like that one I like that one shit I
don't think we need to play that would
you rather I think they already decided
and they are retarded that's what I get
from this Oh Chuck you know what that is
funny
that is why can't blonde count till 70 I
can't think of a reason because 69 is a
bit of a mouthful you say mom doesn't
get it no your mama don't know what that
one your mom has no idea what I know
ideas grant chunk like I don't know what
that no idea I got the high numbers yeah
mmm see I did why did the blonde stare
at a frozen orange juice can for two
hours you know I couldn't come up an
answer for that in a million years
because it said concentrate that's great
oh my that's actually funny that's
really funny
I don't deal with that don't think every
one ago and we like to use aquila would
laugh like that Jason I don't know I
didn't know laughing I couldn't I can't
imagine laughing out loud at that I mean
seriously I didn't think there were
people who thought this shit was really
funny setting to me i nobody would laugh
out loud I know it's an lol for some
people but some people like dead bona
jokes do like this is just this is like
those silly jokes you would read on the
back of a bubblegum wrapper and at most
is worth a smile yeah you go you kind of
smirk at it like oh that's clever The
Closer a joke about a solid joke to
laugh out loud that heart of it
it's frustrating and then you think
doesn't make you wonder like when they
come watch you perform
like what what are they MMS is heart
they've never left records at anything
but what are they thinking of your ACK
if they think this shit's hilarious yeah
well they don't laugh at it think what
happens is I've learned about him he
gauges all he cares about his audience
responds he has no connection to what
I'm doing
he just goes they really like that or
like wow you really had him going
he's entertained by the audience
beginning right he doesn't yeah I got it
Wow Wow it's astounding and I think it's
also very telling that his absolute
favorite favorite favorite by far thing
of mine is my most undeveloped my
elementary level stand up if you will
shy first thing your first your first
joke my first joke a little more oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm basically a you know a new
comic and I'm every night I'm trying to
make this stuff work and it's very kind
of laid out joke joke he's like that's
that's my favorite and anything past
that he's like yeah but you know on that
first one that's all he ever talks about
isn't amazing do you think that do you
think that we'll ever see Ellis who he
is
gin I mean like do you think that every
every generation supposedly you know
gets better at this kind of stuff
emotions oh right acknowledging people
we'll have ours our faults that are
right good do you think that we'll be
able to see our child like truly see and
hear I think much more than we were
seeing than our parents
yeah could it's not amazing it is like
you wonder what do they think of you
like what do they think of us what do
they think of anything it actually I
feel it inside of me when he still
brings that up that first album yeah I
can still like because he doesn't
appreciate the fact that you've evolved
as a comic you're more complex now you
remember lines because you remember when
I'm like dude stop bringing that up stop
saying that that was really funny he
says it like like talking about one of
these jokes
all right side of that guy really good
at dad like okay anyways
yeah I guess never changes and the other
thing is that it's repeated in other
words he'll point the same thing out to
me a hundred times about that yeah like
next week he might go where are you
going I'm going to Tucson buy a good
round that Minnesota thing he did where
you said the guy what's your name yeah
you keep telling me that he certainly
he's living his own moment over and over
you know like he's only in his reality
like he can't if I'm saying he can't
even see what's happening and changing
no no fun it's so fascinating humans are
so fascinating to me yeah what yeah I
love it that was a big one
surprising milan's have TGIF on their
shoes okay if I don't know what it says
rights for any gif on their shoes toes
go in first love la jokes what's the
difference between a blonde and a
mosquito I have no idea a mosquito stops
sucking when you smack it my mom doesn't
know what that means
no clue none oh these are ones I haven't
heard I like all these yeah I could see
the joy in your face oh this is this is
really it's been a great trip going out
here just highlight of a highlighted
trip I know I've never seen somebody
enjoy street jokes as much as you she
loves and I know it's crazy okay jokes
blonde jokes street jokes
oh yeah jokes yeah I do she listened
yeah I think once you learn and keep
repeating and repeating with appearance
you know that yeah I know another one
another one
you know I'm offended by why does a
blonde wear a tight skirt I don't know
to keep her legs closed
oh she got down you hear about the two
blondes they driving down i-75 oh my god
he told me that one a hundred times a
lot of punchline
I was just like he's gonna say it
anyways I'm offended is a very blonde
phobic yeah how offended are you very
deeply I wish you guys respect my hair
color yeah you're you go offend by
thinking about filing suit I'd like to
how about blogging I like to vlog my
feelings I like to tweet about it I like
to demand that your dad get fired from
his job for laughing at these offensive
jokes I'm very offended you very
progressive I scare you how dare you not
agree with me and my point of view and
and very stereotyped us blondes like
that dare you and the sauce on it said
clean restrooms head the time to get to
Miami clean 150 I thought you don't
laugh more snot um what is it called
when a blonde blurt breaking in another
blonde here I give up
windtunnel I'm not supposed to say that
I know I don't know see how I'm not
supposed to say that I know I don't know
those why would that be a joke what's it
called when a blonde blows my blown zir
wind tunnel yep that's the punchline
thank you
right you don't ask for the punch well
so where's the punch line there yeah
yeah thank see now it's an angering me
no fear from your point I keep picturing
my dad those are my dad I'd be I'd be
infuriated too cuz I get your comedian
data transfer oh gosh I love these jokes
and honey you really do why is it good
to have a blonde passenger in your car I
have no idea you can park in the
handicapped zone
forget it I am a nerd these blind dogs
will crack I know I google them
someplace you're all good stuff what are
the worst six years in a blonds life
I don't know third grade
oh my god I'm exhausted I'm tired he's
never laugh at anything any comedian
like no no I know he likes Jay Leno
why should blonde not be given coffee
breaks I give up take too long to
retrain them yeah that's a little em'ly
I like I want alright like yeah it's
good yeah it's really making your five
minutes I can't believe this oh I love
lobster Scott is tough go out forever
and know the reaction so how do you get
a blonde to marry you I don't know tell
her she's pregnant oh boy alright I
think that's enough right if I know
that's a good amount no no honey I want
to tell you about also a good job I want
to tell you about the Caribbean yes
because it has been the best sleep we
have done we had a lot of fun with you
guys
hey no you guys went overboard and loss
generosity kindness I say was it a my
favorite where everything
if the visit is when we went to get
coffee with them at the Country Club
yeah and then we have the people that
don't know the country club means the
mall Armon yeah and then your mom went
into lengthy detail about her urethral
opening surgery I was terrible last time
it was mal practical malpractice suits
and deaths randomly they would just drop
them on you this time it was she had 20
years 30 years 40 years ago she was like
seeing a lot man
and then they're like we're just going
to open your urethra more and the doctor
scheduled it without examining I want to
hear the story it's like such a gross
long story you know my thing that was
funny was that see to me it's very
normal but somebody does what she's
doing now which is tell you their
feelings about how much they appreciate
hate and your own I just so one comes I
hate it she texted us last night like I
want I cracked I can't repeat the text
back to you because I couldn't read it
yeah whenever somebody expresses their
feelings to me yeah I get so
uncomfortable it's just not in my
family if you if you express your
feelings it's a sign of weakness and you
will be ridiculed so funny to me so
nobody just say like thanks for taking
care of us there's a blast are you
creating Latin culture and that about
over selling that right you'll just go
thanks for showing me a good time you
have to go into the detail about you
know all like you remember the things
and like how that made you feel and I
don't know in our house it's thank you
okay thanks okay I got to go like it you
don't need to say thank you once and
then that's it or maybe you send a card
so that you must actually say it yeah
but for me the expression of her
feelings like where she said goodbye to
me last night and she's telling me all
the stuff like I couldn't I mean
couldn't get away fast to go far I can't
get away fast enough last night when
they left oh my god I got a big speech
about their gratitude yeah so what a
great trip yeah
then they both called from the hotel
like an hour later to say it again oh
boy then a text then I woke up to a new
text message and then they called me
again this morning in addition
everything I didn't like yeah it's just
it would never happen in my family never
but the thing is if somebody doesn't say
that it's supposed to mean that they
really didn't have time so in your
family if they don't go over the boat
overboard it means it was just like an
okay trip and you're just a waiver yeah
oh yeah that's a lot it's a lot of
pressure sending about food like if yes
if they try and you go and you go how is
it and somebody goes it's good that
means this isn't good
because if it's really good yeah you
would go on and on you know I really
really like they did about the
restaurant remember how many times
they're talking about it so your dad
didn't like the dinner I made last night
he did like it he did like it
he didn't go go overboard but he did
like it because he talked about it can't
even we well he ate it that's all I care
about
he ate it he must've been hungry yeah I
was good
not his favorite though he likes like
steak I made shrimp them yeah pasta that
was good I liked it a lot
I liked it it's one of our favorites but
yeah the feelings I can't I don't like
it
like I like doing nice things for people
but I don't like to hear the thank you I
don't like it be a bit much yeah it
makes me very uncomfortable there every
second
yeah absolutely can find words to thank
you for these moments and this is it
they the only the only sudden Roger that
I can not make him guys love me yeah I
want him to kiss me to hug me too you
know
no just take time though yeah but I was
here for six days I know that what I
really enjoyed was all the kisses again
I do guys for another book Tommy yeah
all the kisses and hugs and love I got
from Ellis was really really nice I was
version of being like I'm the water
champ see he was trying to jab her with
it it's so interesting that you and I
repeat the same patterns at your parents
he's saying like Oh Ellis gave me a lot
of hugs and kisses oh my god
it's real funny last time you were here
we talked about how there's a whole
segment of the population that's
non-binary do you remember that there's
no way non-binary I think we should read
the bodies later later what a break yeah
let's take a break I love it though I
love listening to them I laughed at them
all week they were here you know
sweating they're so funny Vincent
D'Onofrio babe and shit like that I'm a
free good guy yeah this is a here we do
this this is something that maybe will
cleanse the palate and then we can wrap
up the show okay fuck my Triple D slut
life yeah yeah that of course the I
forgot that decided get the old trumpet
out today now blank this guy can play
the trumpet like you wouldn't believe
oh my goodness he's farting into his
trumpet Wow incredible have we found a
new king aspirin I don't know but this
guy I mean he's got a cool wig can't i
faint humming when i I know when you
discover something big on your mom's
house you feel it yeah like when we
discovered King a stripper that was a
big find there's been a few of those
yeah this feels special it does I mean I
like that he's wearing a lab coat
and that wig he needs to get rid of it
to me he doesn't need those Beatrix oh I
think it dresses it up it becomes more
of a performance because he's he's just
Ted you know when he's wearing his
regular clothes and now he's this but
trumpet match doctor doctor trumpeter
way up it's pretty neat Wow focus yeah
you really got to put that up on there
tight yeah even just to do your mouth
it's very hard to blow a trumpet acts
yeah that's really real talent this come
out there are more hope we get to see
more from dr. black trumpet dr. butt
trumpet all right
wow what a talent that's a gene um
anything else no I oh I know now we've
already done our dates yeah so that's
that's in the past there you go thank
you guys for listening
mm-hmm I love you John C gene we'll see
you next week bye guys
where
[Music]
Oh
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
Killman
I can't imagine what the enthusiasm
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's the most disturbing dead-on
at all yeah